it is with great sadness that we report
that the chairman of Rochford District
Council Councillor Derek stands be and
the ward member for hullbridge
councillor Peter Robinson passed away in
april here the leader of Rochford
District Council Councillor Terry cut
more pays tribute to both members I had
known and had been a firm friend of both
Derek stands be and his wife Doris for
many years and was greatly saddened by
the news of his passing away he was a
well-respected and quietly spoken man
that those who knew him well hid an
underlying passion for getting the best
for his ward his district and his county
I am pleased however that he had reached
the point of being the chairman of the
council and therefore the first citizen
of Rochford district his picture now
hangs in the council chamber where he
had participated in many debates this
will continue continually remind us of
him and how he always made his points
well and with a passion I have spoken
all my heart goes out his loving wife
Doris who has stood by him and comforted
him whilst he had been ill I shall miss
him it was with both surprised and
sadness that I heard of the passing on
of Peter Robinson Peter was a great
character and always had a great
interest in all things technical he had
a run our video presentation business
and was the council's member champion
for a government and website development
from 2007 to 2010 he also served the
council as vice chairman of our leisure
tourism and Heritage Committee and
represented the hullbridge ward of the
council his wife Dorothy or dot as we
all know her has lovingly supported
Peter through his illness and I feel
very sad for her loss Peter was her life
he will be greatly missed by all
district elections and referendum the
results only the fifth there are
elections for a lot to the district
council as well as parish councils and a
referendum on the voting system for UK
parliamentary elections elections from
the district council took place in the
following Ward's down hall aurorus
grange hall north south west hockley
central hullbridge lodge rochford and
swain park the wards of ashenden
includin barling on sutton and fell
lesson great wakering were uncontested
there were also elections for the
following parish councils Culloden the
ashington ward of ashington parish and
the great wakering east ward of great
wakering parish all other parishes were
uncontested the referendum at present
the UK uses the first-past-the-post
system to elect MPs to the House of
Commons should the alternative vote
system be used instead the yes vote was
5542 and the no vote was twenty thousand
nine hundred and thirty-one rejected
papers 487 and the local turnout was 41
point 0 2 percent
following the local elections in May
there are 39 councillors representing 19
walls or areas the district and the
political composition of the council is
as follows 31 conservative councillors
for liberal Democrat councillors one
green councillor to Rochford district
residents councillors and there is one
vacant space meetings of the executive
and the main statutory and regular
committees are usually held at the Civic
sweet Raley and are open to members of
the public there may occasionally be
some items of confidential business when
the public will be asked to leave the
meeting there is also a review committee
which is there to help review and
develop areas of work members of the
public who have written in about a
planning application may register to
speak at the development committee when
that application is being considered
guidance on public speaking of the
development committee can be obtained
from member services or from the council
website please contact member services
on 0170 2318 140 for details of the
meetings or check the council's website
at www k
your local councillors are as follows
ashington anchor neweden mrs. TJ cape on
and TG cut more both conservative
barling and sutton NJ steptoe
conservative down hall and rawrus CI
black and ra autumn both lib dem
fairness and great wakering te goodwin
cg segars and mrs. bj wilkins or
conservative and grange CJ Lumley and
mrs. J are Lumley both lib dem
Hawk will north rd pointer mrs. JD
McPherson conservative hawk was south p
a Capon and mrs. H la glyn conservative
hawk or west jrf mason a mrs. CM mason
Rochford district residents hotly
central KH Hudson mrs. C a westin jay
thomas conservative hotly north mr
carter conservative hotly west and
maddox conservative hullbridge m ahoy
Green Party this is av hail conservative
and there is one vacant position lodge d
merrick and IH Ward conservative
rayleigh central mrs. P out and AJ
Humphreys conservative Rockford mrs. G a
Lucas Gil k j gordon and JP Coty's or
conservative Swain park mrs. J a
Montford nte mountain conservatives
Trinity K a dibs and je grey both
conservative wintley a priest and mrs.
MJ Webster both conservative and white
house PFA Webster and SP Smith both
conservatives
for the third year in a row there was a
huge response to rot for District
Council's poster competition we receive
several high quality entries this year
from young people via their school
college academy or youth group the
poster competition for young people was
held to support national food safety
week from the sixth of the 12th of June
the competition was to design a poster
to promote the benefits of healthy
eating or not smoking and help raise
levels of awareness of the issues for
young people congratulations to the
winners grace cook year six Edward
Francis junior school won the poster
competition promoting healthy eating for
the 8 to 12 years and Shaunie Hardy year
11 Swain part school won the post of
group promoting the benefits of not
smoking for 11 to 16 year olds the
winners in each category received a
30-pound gift voucher and certificate
120 pound for this school college
Academy all youth group wrought for
district councils head of Environmental
Services Richard Evans said once again
we have had a great response to our
poster competition it was incredibly
hard to pick winners this year from all
the wonderful enters we had in it's
great to see so many wonderful entries
from young people in the district I've
been so creative in getting messages out
there about the benefits of healthy
eating and not smoking
out and about rayleigh horticultural
society has its autumn show coming up on
Sunday September the fourth there will
be displays of flowers vegetables floral
art and home crafts the show will be
held at the mill arts & Events Center in
bellingham Lane and is open to the
public from two o'clock till four thirty
in the afternoon admission is one pound
for adults and accompany children are
free this free parking nearby and
further information and contact details
are on the society's website at WWE Hall
a cultural society co uk hot glue manner
netball club meets at green thought
academy in hotly on Friday nights years
1 2 3 & 4 will be there between
four-thirty and five-thirty p.m. years 5
& 6 from 5 30 to 6 30 and year 7 3 30 to
4 30 no experience is needed come and
have some fun meet new friends and learn
new skills and the contact details for
that is tracy reason 07 956 double 28
double 58 Debi Moore 07 90 110 6223 or
you can email TD multi hyphen sports at
hotmail co dot uk' girls cricket at
rankings cricket club stanbridge road
rockford meets every friday night from
615 to 7 30p n all ages are welcome
contact scott 0 double 7 7 6 185 504 and
the london 2012 open weekend dreams and
memories drop-in session as at clements
hall leisure center ss5 for ln on Friday
the twenty-second of July between 10am
and 12 noon this is your chance to
contribute to a national archive
recording opinions on
london 2012 olympic and paralympic games
and the contact number for this is 0 1
702 31 8 121
great wakering farmers market will be
held at the community center the old
school high street great weight free on
the third saturday of the month until
november ten a.m. to 1pm for the details
contact 0170 2218 631 and Rochford's
farmers market will be held at the WI
hall west street rochford on the first
saturday of the month except in january
between nine thirty AM and 1230pm
contact the client to Rochford Parish
Council on 0 1 702 540 722 or email
Clark at Rochford Parish Council that's
all on word golf doc UK and now here are
some council meeting dates development
committee meets on the thirtieth of June
the review committee on the twelfth of
July the executive on the thirteenth of
July council meeting on the twenty-first
of July Development Committee 28th of
July develop committee again or a
twenty-fifth of August the review
committee thirteenth of September the
executive on the twenty-first of
September development committee the
twenty-second of September all meetings
start at seven thirty p.m. and will be
held at the Civic sweet in hot key road
all meetings are subject to change so
for more information contact members
services on 0 1 702 318 140
an out-and-about special how to give
your business a boost this summer
rochford District Council is always keen
to hear from local businesses which may
need to access services but council is
involved in several projects to help
give your business a boost and there are
plenty of ways to get involved whether
it's the award-winning shop at my local
campaign the ROG the business network or
the low carb and business project
there's access to help and support
across the board why not head for the
freight house for the next roxford
business network business breakfast on
wednesday 29th of june between 730am and
10am this event will provide information
from the low-carbon business team about
how your business can access grant
funding speakers will include peter
wohnen program manager Christopher C
mark grants officer and rod Robinson
green business advisor who will be
available to answer any of your
questions for more information or to
book your free place please email
business at oxford WK or call zero one
seven zero to 3 1 80 60 if you're unable
to attend the business breakfast then
don't worry you can find out more about
the council's economic development team
on our website at WWF a govt UK